this is like your nightmare tonight
honestly I can't even say I've liked
right thing ever so I'm actually not the
best Baker okay if it's a microwave what
I really do love to bake I'm actually
very excited for this we're gonna have
you make it without a recipe what oh my
god what hey wait wait are you guys
gonna give me instructions no this is
not gonna go well at all without a
recipe I've seen a mug cake on Instagram
several times but I've never made one
myself like dump everything in a mug and
I guess microwave it it seems really
bootleg putting it on a microwave I
don't know I don't trust it where do you
begin
oh my god I feel more comfortable this
table is like full of like live snakes
what is this what the hell is this oh
butter yeah let's take a trip in the
milk town that actually looks like too
much okay I almost forgot sugar like
that's really important just okay there
goes the shell this is like the most
stressful thing I've ever done something
about this is wrong
I'm getting some type of play-doh
mixture now sugars build Jesus Christ
that is so much right now I think this
is gonna taste terrible I'm gonna hook
up this microwave sorry jazz it up
but these rainbow sprinkles in there it
looks very disgusting but I'm proud of
it it's looking a little watery so this
is gonna come out terribly let's go for
like
and I think that a mug cake would
probably take 5 minutes and now we wait
we're closing in on the final seconds
here Oh oh my god I opened the door and
I saw the cake move like a lot um the
top seems like it's ready there's
actually some inside that looks pretty
cake like like this I would eat I think
I'm gonna try it the top looks like a
Jurassic Park egg but it's like goo like
it doesn't want to read it almost looks
like poop from a baby diaper it is dense
[Music]
it looks bad but doesn't but I also
don't want to finish it you guys it's
really good it's really good kind of has
a cakey vibe to it it's definitely not
good kind of looks like EP like you say
even it's exactly like tape I did a
pretty good job it doesn't even taste
like a cake it tastes like a pancake
it's a pink piece of cake I got a little
cocky with the sprinkles it just had no
flavor
other than that softly like a meeting
chocolate and play-doh I don't know what
Plato tastes like but I'm I'm assuming
this is how plate over tastes